WALMART SALARIES:
Salaries at Walmart have become
insane. Software engineers for example can expect
to earn as much as half a million per year. Now,
such salaries aren’t too crazy at big tech
companies and VC funded startups but Walmart isn’t
either of those. They’re a retailer, a legacy
retailer. For perspective, the top engineers
at Target earn over $200,000 less at $278,000.
And at Costco, the average software engineer is
barely able to cross a $100,000. This doesn’t
just apply for software engineers either. For
product managers, they’re offering up to $500,000.
For engineering managers, they’re offering up to
$600,000. And even for data scientists, they’re
offering up to $400,000. In fact, Walmart is
paying so much that for certain tech job titles,
they’re literally on the leaderboard for paying
the highest compensation. Take Solution Architect
for example. Walmart comes in as the 24th highest
paying company for this position with a median
of $223,000. This places them just $2,000 behind
Apple and $3,000 behind Facebook. This also places
them ahead of some of the largest tech companies
out there including Cisco, Salesforce, Oracle,
and Dell. We should also note that Walmart is
the only retailer that makes the leaderboard other
than Amazon of course but they’re more of a tech
company than a retailer. Walmart on the other hand
is definitely still more of a retailer but they’re
leaning into tech more than ever. In fact, they
have a full on subsidiary called Walmart Global
Tech, formerly known as Walmart Labs, with
8000 employees. Why does a retailer need this
many tech employees? Well, it’s because Walmart
doesn’t treat tech as an addition to their retail
business, they treat tech as the basis of their
retail business. But, it wasn’t always like this.
In fact, for nearly 16 years, Walmart had stalled
out. But since 2015, the retailer has tripled
their market cap growing to a valuation of just
under $400 billion making them the 19th largest
company in the world. So, here’s the story of how
Walmart saved their stagnating business with tech.
WALMART THE BOOMER:
Taking a look back, Walmart’s transition into
tech can be traced back to the late 1990s when
Walmart was very much the boomers of the retail
industry. By this point, they were already the
largest retailers in the US and the world’s
largest private employer. In fact, Walmart still
holds this title to this day with a whopping
2.3 million employees. But, while things were
going great at Walmart, they were starting a see
a little thorn pop up called Amazon, you may have
heard of them. At first, they started off as a no
name online bookstore, but every year, they were
growing by hundreds if not thousands of percent.
They were expanding into new categories all the
time and it seemed like they wanted to be the
Walmart of the online world. In fact, they were
starting to poach a bunch of Walmart employees by
luring them with sky high stock compensation. This
made it easy for Amazon to steal Walmart’s world
class logistics and supply chain secrets. Usually,
when an up and coming competitor is able to steal
your employees and perform extraordinarily well,
it’s usually a sign that they’re doing something
that you’re not. With the case of Amazon,
the X factor was obviously their online presence.
So, the best idea would’ve probabaly been for
Walmart to poach some tech employees from Amazon
and double down on the online space. In fact,
this is precisely what they’ve been doing over
the past several years. But, back in the day,
Walmart would take the boomer approach and
try to bog down Amazon by suing them. While
that fiasco was going on at Walmart, our story
jumps over two tech enterpreneurs named Venky
Harinarayan and Anand Rajaraman. These guys were
your classic tech guys from India having both
completed degrees at IIT in India and Stanford
in America. They had gone on to create an online
company called Junglee Corporation which allowed
shoppers to easily compares prices and features
of various online products. This is nothing
crazy today, but back in the 1990s, this was
revolutionary stuff and Jeff Bezos would take
interest in the company. In 1998, he would buy
out the Junglee for 1.6 million shares of Amazon
which at the time was worth $250 million. Today,
it’s worth $22 billion, so safe to say that these
two had scored a pretty lucrative deal but they
were by no means ready to retire. Both Venky and
Anand would join Amazon as high level directors
and closely work with Jeff Bezos himself. These
two would actually end up being instrumental in
the launch of Amazon marketplace. You may not be
familiar with this brand but I’m sure you know
what they do. This is the part of Amazon that
allows for third party sellers to list products
onto Amazon. As you know, this is basically
the bread and butter of Amazon today, so it
looks like Bezos definitely got his money’s worth
with this duo. Now, while that’s cool and all,
you’re probably wondering, what in the world
do these guys have to do with Walmart. Well,
these two are the ones that would create what
would eventually become Walmart Global Tech.
WALMART FEELS THE PAIN:
After helping Bezos launch
Amazon marketplace, our duo would help
him launch Amazon Mechanical Turk. This
is basically the Fiverr of the corporate world.
Companies can outsource brute force work like
data validation and content moderation through
Amazon. By the time Mechnical Turk came out,
Venky and Anand had spent the better part of a
decade at Amazon, and they started to feel that it
was time to move on. They didn’t directly switch
over to Walmart though. They would actually lean
back into entrepreneurship and start another
company together called Kosmix. Kosmix was a
rather niche company but it was extremely valuable
for the enterprise customers that were in that
niche. What did Kosmix do you ask? Well, they
specialized in search engine optimization. More
specifically, they aimed to transform vertical
search engines into horizontal search engines.
Vertical searching is the most rudimentary type
of searching. It’s when people enter a keyword
and the engine searches a given database for
matches. Horizontal searching on the other hand
is more like the YouTube algorithm. It uses
the keyword that you entered along with your
previous searches and purchases to display the
products that you would be most likely to buy
as opposed the products that are the closest
match to the keyword that you entered. Again,
standard stuff nowadays, but novel concept back in
the 2000s. Venky and Anand would go onto build an
encyclopedia of nearly 5 million categories with
hundreds and hundred of parameters. For example,
they accounted for where customers were
searching from, what car did they drive,
what music they listen to, and even what type
of cheese they like. You could use all these
parameters to display products that would be
the most likely to convert into sales. So,
for obvious reasons, this technology was extremely
valuable for retailers and they would eat it up.
Kosmix would end up growing hundreds of percent
per year, partner with several organizations,
and even acquire smaller companies. So, Kosmix was
no doubt killing it but the same could not be said
about Walmart. Walmart wasn’t exactly doing bad,
but they weren’t exactly doing well either. You
see, maturity had hit Walmart like a ton of bricks
and they were feeling the pain. During the 80s and
90s, Walmart had grown a ridiculous 60X putting
all other retailers to shame but for 10 years now,
Walmart had gone nowhere. If the industry as
a whole had stagnated, this wouldn’t be too
big of a problem but e commerce was still growing
exponentially and Walmart was simply missing out.
They did have an online presence but compared to
Amazon, this was largely a joke. In fact, if you
navigate back to their 2010 website, you’re hit
with a “Adobe Flash player is no longer supported”
warning. Amazon on the other hand already had
a recommended section and was already evolving
into its current form. Walmart clearly needed to
pivot but if they wanted to stage such a large
turnaround, they needed the help of experts. And
what better experts to hire than the former Amazon
directors that helped launch Amazon Marketplace
and were now working on a highly valuable search
engine. And with that, Walmart would acquire
Kosmix for $300 million in cash in early 2011.
WALMART PIVOTS:
It’s easy to say that Walmart just bought their
way into tech but that’s not really the case. Yes,
they had a lot of help from Kosmix but Walmart
deserves a bunch of credit as well. Usually
with acquisitions, companies try to integrate
the child company into the parent company. They
want the child company to adopt the same culture,
the same philosophies, the same salary bands, and
so on. Walmart on the other hand decided to take
a much different approach. They could clearly tell
that what they were already doing wasn’t working.
So, it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to force
this up and coming company to also do same thing.
Instead, they would decide to adapt Walmart to
what Kosmix was doing. This takes an insane amount
of humility and most companies would never make
such a pivot but Walmart did. While all of their
peers were paying legacy company tech salaries
like AT&T and IBM, Walmart was paying FAANG level
salaries or atleast as close as they could get.
Obviously, they would never be able to pay as much
as actual tech companies as they simply don’t have
the same margins. But, for a physical retailer,
they were paying extraordinary amounts. This
allowed them to recruit some of the best talent
out there including a bunch of Amazon employees
who were trying to escape the toxic work culture
at Amazon. Suddenly, Walmart had all the resources
they needed to build a modern online platform and
that’s exactly what they would do. But, they
didn’t just blindly copy Amazon. They did
indeed add their own twist. One of the biggest
bottlenecks for Amazon is their fulfillment
centers. To continue driving down delivery times,
Amazon has keep opening up fulfillment centers
that are increasingly omnipresent. I mean, if you
wanna deliver within 24 hours to any address, you
need fulfillment centers within 24 hours of every
address. That’s kind of how that works. But, the
problem with opening so many fulfillment centers
is that you quickly reach the point of diminishing
returns. Opening more centers becomes more
expensive than its worth, but if you wanna keep
driving down delivery times to 2 hours and 1 hour,
that’s the only way. But see, this isn’t nearly as
big of an issue for Walmart because well, they’re
already omnipresent atleast within the US. In
fact, the average American lives within 4.2 miles
of a Walmart. So, forget 1 hour delivery, Walmart
could do 15 minute delivery. All they needed to
do was convert their thousands of stores into high
tech warehouses, and that’s exactly what they’ve
been doing. Walmart Global Tech could handle all
of the AI and machine learning involved in running
such a large retail operation. What products
needed to be carried by which stores and when.
What routes do their trucks need to make to ensure
that every store has what they need and so on and
so forth. Meanwhile, Walmart’s legacy business
could focus on logistics, fulfillment, and
customer satisfaction. This strategy was already
working out well in the 2010s, but the pandemic
changed things up big time. You see, Walmart
had one thing that Amazon is still struggling to
offer: fresh groceries for pick up and delivery.
And this was exactly the advantage Walmart needed
to cement themselves as an ecommerce juggernaut.
THE TECH WALMART:
Today,
Walmart has been able to regain the momentum that
they had lost in the 2000s. Over the past 7 years,
their stock has tripled and their fundamentals
have led the way. In fact, Walmart is the
number one revenue driver in the entire world
pulling in a crazy $600 billion per year. Now,
I do want to note that their earnings have not
kept up with their revenue growth but this isn’t
really a concern. The main reason for this is
simply that Walmart has been investing much of
their profits into the tech side of the business
and revenue growth. And for modern companies,
growth is simply way more valuable than the bottom
line. Amazon for example is still not profitable
but they’re worth over a trillion dollars. So,
it looks like Walmart has not only adapted to
modern tech but they’ve adapted to ther modern
business landscape. And that is why Walmart is
so successful to this day. Did you realize how
much Walmart was paying their tech workers?
Comment that down below. Also, drop a like if you
would like to see more videos about the evolution
of companies. And of course, consider checking
out our discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered.